[Applaudissements]
la vérité est une ligne tracée entre les
erreurs cette voie que l'on vient
d'entendre est une voix de synthèse une
voie créée de toutes pièces la voix la
voix c'est le graal des interfaces entre
l'homme et la machine
demain dans votre salon il y aura des
conversations entre syrie alexa erika
elle vous poseront des questions et vous
pourrez parfois ont posé aussi parfois
elle vous répondront des chercheurs
comme moi travaillent dur pour donner
une certaine humanité à ses voix certain
naturel à l'intelligence dit artificiel
ça fait 15 ans que je cherche la voix
parfaite à l'ircam l'ircam institut de
recherche et de coordination acoustique
pour la science musique pour l'art a
lieu dans lequel se croisent chercheurs
et artistes autour de la même passion la
musique
un jour un compositeur vient me voir et
me demande s'il peut utiliser cette voie
de synthèse dans son spectacle
il veut lui faire dire des poèmes
imprononçable dans des langues
imaginaires quelque chose comme sa vie
ou non de dormir nous mettez des aspects
temps malgré mon désir porsche de saint
hilaire le lointain de derrière que leur
sens auditif plan d'heure de la lumière
tableau de primitifs alors tel de
docteur frankenstein on commence à
construire un comédien virtuel capable
de déclamer des vers l'entreprise est
complexe
aussi complexe que les la richesse de
l'expression humaine et après quelques
fausses pistes quelques tentatives
infructueuses et plusieurs usines à gaz
mon compositeur grec me dit mais
j'aimerais lui expliquer avec mme emma à
cette voix de synthèse comment il faut
s'exprimer
et là c'est le déclic
immédiatement mon équipe et moi nous
penchons sur le geste
ce geste qui accompagne naturellement
l'expression de la parole grâce à une
série de capteurs on commence à barder
notre compositeur et avec un peu
d'entraînement on arrive à donner une
certaine humanité à cette voix de
synthèse
aujourd'hui elle se porte un petit peu
mieux
la vérité est une ligne du tracé entre
les erreurs ce compositeur nous a montré
la partie imaginaire d'un problème qui
était bien réel pour nous ce genre de
rencontre entre le chercheur que je suis
et l'artiste qu'il est n'a finalement
rien d'exceptionnel l'art et la science
sont un vieux couple dont la technologie
et l'émerveillement sont les enfants
la légende raconte que la rencontre
entre les mathématiques et la musique
s'est produite le jour où pythagore se
promener près de l'atelier d'un forgeron
ils entendent et sonorité harmonieuse
les marteaux qui frappe les enclumes il
est séduit il rentre dans l'atelier il
interrompt le forgeron il pèse les
masses est il écrit les équations
mathématiques de l'harmonie musicale
l'histoire des arts et des sciences est
parsemé de rencontres et de similarité
des affinités esthétique comme la
joconde et le nombre d'or la suite de
fibonacci et ce prélude de bach en fait
artistes et chercheurs ont toujours
travaillé ensemble des ateliers
florentin de la renaissance à ceux de
jeff koons ou jean nouvelle aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce que artistes et
chercheurs utilisent les mêmes outils
hier la plume et le compas pour leonardo
davinci aujourd'hui l'informatique et
l'intelligence artificielle
en fait artistes et chercheurs partagent
les mêmes ressources
l'intuition l'expérimentation la raison
le parcours d'une d'une oeuvre
artistique ou d'une découverte
scientifique n'est pas une ligne droite
qui va de a à b c'est une ligne droite
qui part de à
et puis ensuite b n'arrête pas de bouger
on va par si on est happé par là on va
contourner une difficulté on a envie de
changer de direction
alors on teste on fait des hypothèses on
expérimente et on se trompe on fait des
erreurs et c'est tant mieux parce que
c'est grâce à ces erreurs que
j'appellerais plutôt des lapsus que
petit à petit on rebondit vers un bep
qu'on était bien incapable d'imaginer au
départ l'erreur l'erreur vient du latin
et rae rae l'errance vagabonder on
connaît tous leurs oeufs erreur de
christophe colomb qui lui a fait
découvrir le nouveau continent
on connaît un peu moins la fosse
intuition du physicien danois niels bohr
sur un modèle à tommy qui s'est trompé
mais il a ouvert la porte à la mécanique
quantique reconnaître l'erreur savoir en
tirer partie être capable de changer de
direction
ça demande une certaine ouverture
d'esprit un certain rapport au monde une
écoute des autres un éveil à l'instant
comment se tromper aujourd'hui dans une
société basée sur l'efficacité la
rentabilité le rendement le gain direct
qui jamais ne s'arrête sur ses erreurs
et si le meilleur moyen d'accélérer le
progrès s'était de ralentir et de se
réunir entre nous et de produire des
lapsus dont certains seront révélateurs
mais faisons le sérieusement organisons
nous rencontrons nous autour de feux de
bois avec d'illustrés inconnus pour
refaire le monde et laisser libre cours
à nos idées posez vous cette question
aujourd'hui il est où mon feu de bois à
moi mon feu de bourrage l'alimentent à
l'ircam grâce au compositeur et aux
chercheurs avec qui je travaille et au
sein d'une compagnie la compagnie sîn
équine que j'ai créée suite à la
collision avec ce compositeur on y
travaille ces notions ses relations
entre le geste la voix les émotions la
danse la musique les nouvelles
technologies aujourd'hui je suis heureux
de vous présenter le fruit d'une
expérience menée avec dalila khatir sous
la forme d'une improvisation je ne sais
pas exactement où ça va nous mener
et c'est tant mieux comme ça
ouh ouh ouh ouh ouh ouh
[Musique]
oh
oh oh oh
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]